hello everyone if there's anyone in the
chess world that doesn't need
introduction it's definitely Maurice
actually the gangsta chess commentator
that can make any any chess match sound
like a football game and this game he's
playing against the Sun Oliveira mantri
the game was played in 1991 and sort of
our mantra is actually nakamura
stepfather and his early childhood the
chess coach so let's see this game
between Maurice Ashley and Nakamura
stepfather we have a four by Maurice and
now d6 the first defense d4 g6 Knight to
c3 Bishop to g7 Bishop to e3 and okay we
can already see that Maurice is ready to
attack with the formation of Bishop III
Queen d2 and f3 and going for Bishop h7
and exchanging that dark square Bishop
so c6 we have Queen to d2 b v f3 Knight
to d7 and Maurice goes h4 ready to push
g4 and h5 and what do we have h5 by mr.
Asuna we have Knight to h3 night to be
6/9 to g5 now and rook to b8
and here mr. Rahman 3 is ready to push a
5 and B for himself and attack on the
Queen side and so Maurice plays Knight
to d1 well this is just removing the
knife to e3 after it the bishop moves
and well who knows where it's gonna go
after that we have b5 Bishop to f4 rip
the b7 and now II five this is a locking
this dark square Bishop pretty much out
of the game so we have an eye to h6
Bishop to d3 and now Knight to f5 and
well okay here definitely Maurice would
want to exchange this night so Bishop
captures an f5 and our Bishop captures
an f5 and we have nice 293 now
threatening to capture this Bishop and
to break open the Kings side but Mr
Spenlow mantra finds an interesting move
he plays Knight to c4 and he attacks
maurices Queen and also well if Maurice
doesn't want to lose the Queen you'll
have to exchange this night and this
would favor
like indeed if this B file got opened
but actually Maurice finds a nice
against a move and he plays nice
captures an f5 parting with his queen
and also threatening knife captures here
on g7 so okay the Queen sacrifice is
accepted we have a nice capture Sun v2
and now Knight captures and g7 would
check and we have Kings to d7 bug black
if black tried something like King to f8
then this is a completely winning for
white you'd get 96 with check F captures
night tonight captures on e6 again now
check for King the king and queen king
288 now grabbing the Queen Knight
captures on d8 and now well this Black
Knight is still attacked so you do have
to at least use it somehow so Knight
captures on f3 would check at least
grabbing upon G captures night and now
King captures on the 8th and as you can
see white is happily up a bishop so
after Knight to g7 check by Maurice
would have a link to d7 and now again a
very nice continuation by Maurice e6
check and this isn't any tricky
attacking move this is simply to open up
this bishops diagonal is this is now a
very powerful piece we have Kings to see
it and now not not capturing this night
as if King captures night you get
Queen to b6 attacking that d4 pawn king
to e3 defending and now f6 attacking the
knight Knight to f7 and now Rock to g8
and what this night really doesn't have
anywhere to go
so if white would want to keep his space
piece he would have to play Bishop to
Bishop h6 now protecting that night and
well as you can see White has three
pieces up here doing absolutely nothing
just to protect this one piece and black
is ready to push c5 and black is better
here so after kink the c8 Maurice plays
he captures on f7 and already that's a
very dangerous passed pawn on the 7th
rank we have a knight back to c4 as the
night was still attacked and d2 night to
e6 attacking the Queen we have a queen
to F I would check and how King to have
to Queen to b4
threatening that that pawn on b2 and now
b3 of course defending we are right to
be 6
and now Maurice finds another great idea
he plays c-3po offering another pawn to
open up the see file so we have Queen
captures on c3 and now rook the c1 we
have a queen to be to check King to f1
and rook to b6 now protecting that c6
bone from the rook but here Maurice
finds another way into the position
plays first rook a to be one attacking
the Queen the Queen kit but the Queen
has nowhere to go she can either go to
a3 or capture the pawn on a2 so we have
Queen captures an a2 and now rook to a1
and now after the Queen moves open
capture some b3 Maurice grabs this pawn
on a7 and on blacks position is getting
very uncomfortable Maurice is
threatening to capture this pawn here
there are ideas like rook to c7 check
and such and there is really not a good
move for mr. little mantra here so he
plays he tries a rook to b7 defending
but Maurice just captures it rook
captures from b7 we have Knight captures
on b7 and not simply rook captures on c6
would check and in this position mr. su
novia de montreuil resigned the game
because there is only one move for him
to play and that is king 37 and after
king 37 is played Oh
after King 37 is played simply rook to
c7 and this is checkmate so yeah I mean
look at this position and not once did
well not once did Marissa actually try
to put this f8 to grab this rook on h8
because this rook on h8 was doing
nothing for the entire game and this
night on e6 was definitely a monster
night so yeah definitely a beautiful
game by Maurice Ashley and I don't know
maybe he joined the commentators a bit
too soon if he was able to produce
beautiful games like this so yeah that's
it I do hope you enjoyed this game by by
a famous chess commentator today but as
you can see a great player before and
yeah as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and I will see you soon